[Musique]
l'exposition de manet à picasso trésor
de l'adjoint l'ex bourg art gallery et
du musée léon dierx commence à prendre
un ses formes ce matin le régisseur
s'activent pour encadrer les oeuvres que
je fais c'est d'encadrer les picasso
déjà on avait quatre ans là que
l'afrique du sud c'est encadré c'est
déjà accroché au mieux
par la suite
j'ai encadré 2 go gagnent aussi
picasso gauguin sont désormais accrochés
aux murs du musée léon dierx les traits
de crayon uniques qui font de ces
peintres des incontournables de cette
période picasso côté de vollard qu
l'immense honneur de se faire tirer le
portrait par picasso les offres
commencent à se parler entre elles et la
vision pro forme
des noms qui le propriétaire des lieux
qui est le propriétaire des collections
le musée léon dierx
possède à travers le musée landes hier
la première collection impressionniste
en dehors du territoire métropolitain
c'est la plus grande collection
d'oeuvres de la fin du 19e siècle et du
début du 20e siècle qu'il existait dans
les outre-mer français donc c'est
vraiment la réunion à la chance
de posséder ce musée puisque tous les
noms que vous avez institutions deux
gars caillebotte valtat maurice denis
renoir
et j'en oublie d'autres qui sont bons
qui seront présentés alors à travers
beaucoup de d'estampés de documents de
lithographie gravure tous ces grands
noms sont aujourd'hui et non extrêmement
célèbre pouvoir confronter les
collections du musée léon dierx avec les
collections françaises de la javanaise
burghardt galerie parce que ce sont deux
établissements qui ont été ouverts créé
en même temps au début du 20e siècle
avec des parties de collection très
semblables donc l'idée de croiser les
collections pour compléter l'une avec
l'autre était un exercice en même temps
assez complexe parce qu'on est dans un
périmètre délimité et en même temps très
passionnant puisque de manet à picasso
on va pouvoir découvrir tous les
artistes importants de l'époque sous une
forme moins connu que leur peinture par
exemple puisqu'ils si la majorité des
oeuvres sont des estampes les cadres ont
été préparées à l'avancé avant même
l'arrivée des oeuvres de la lyonnaise
pour art gallery vivien s'activent il
lui reste beaucoup destans par encadré
en fonction de l'ordre
encadrement et l'accrochage chaque étape
est fait avec précaution les offres
devront être retournés dans le même état
dans lequel ils sont arrivés
sont en bon état
et 28 hockey de l'autre côté on s'active
à l'accrochage il reste beaucoup de
travail et quelques heures avant que ne
s'ouvrent cette exposition unique qui
permettra aux réunionnais de toucher des
yeux des artistes universel une première
pour la réunion est une première dans
l'océan indien
c'est pas la peine d'aller au musée
d'orsay vous voulez découvrir le public
réunionnais veut découvrir des oeuvres
d'artistes extrêmement connue
extrêmement célèbres qui appartiennent
au patrimoine
français le musée léon dierx a la chance
d'avoir quasiment tous afin d'avoir tous
ces grands noms et d'avoir des offres
qui permettent justement d'accéder et de
comprendre à quel point tous ces
artistes à un moment ils ont
complètement révolutionné la façon de
voir le monde et c'est ça qui est
important et le musée léon dierx est
amusé capital à la réunion et même dans
la zone océan indien et avec une aura
qui est vraiment une aura internationale
puisque on a des offres ici que nous
envient beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
musées dans le monde
l'exposition de manet à picasso ouvrira
ses portes le samedi 26 novembre au
public et réunionnais pourront alors
voir les trésors de la dijonnaise pour
art gallery et du musée léon dierx et
même s'ils manient semaine à picasso par
ses chemins sont aussi passés augusto
monnoir edgar degas ou encore auguste
rodin à découvrir plus de 200
chef-d'oeuvre pour la première fois
exposé à l'île de la réunion
[Musique]